Chris Anderson: William, hola. Me alegro de verte.
William Kamkwamba: Gracias.
CA: Entonces, tenemos una imagen aquí, ¿creo? ¿Dónde esta esto?
WK: Este es mi hogar. Ahí es donde yo vivo.
CA: ¿Dónde? ¿Qué país?
WK: En Malawi, Kasungu. En Kasungu. Sí, Mala.
CA: OK. Ahora, ¿tienes 19 años?
WK: Sí, tengo 19, ahora.
CA: Cinco años atrás tuviste una idea, ¿Cúal era?
WK: Quería construir un molino de viento.
CA: ¿Un molino de viento?
WK: Sí.
CA: ¿Y entonces qué?, ¿para iluminación y cosas así?
CA: Entonces, ¿qué hiciste? ¿Cómo lo llevaste a cabo?
WK: Después de abandonar la escuela, fui a la biblioteca,
y leí un libro -- "Uso de la Energía"
y encontre información acerca de construir el molino.
Y lo intenté y lo hice.
(Aplausos)
CA: Entonces tu copiaste -- tu exactamente copiaste el diseño del libro.
WK: Ah, no. Yo solo --
CA: ¿Qué ocurrió?
WK: De hecho, el diseño del molino de viento que estaba en el libro,
tenía 4 -- ah -- 3 aspas,
y el mío tenía 4.
CA: El libro tenía 3 y el tuyo tenía 4.
WK: Sí.
CA: y ¿lo construiste a partir de qué?
WK: Hice 4 aspas, porque quería aumentar la potencia.
CA: OK.
WK: Sí.
CA: ¿Tú probaste 3 y descubriste que 4 funcionaban mejor?
WK: SI. Hice pruebas.
CA: ¿Y de qué hiciste el molino de viento?
¿Qué materiales usaste?
WK: Utilicé: un cuadro de bicicleta, una polea y tubos plásticos que luego tiran --
CA: ¿Tenemos imágenes de eso?, ¿podemos pasar a la siguiente imagen?
WK: Si. El molino de viento.
CA: Y ese molino de viento -- ¿funcionó?
WK: Cuando el viento sopla, rota y genera.
CA: ¿Cuánta electricidad?
WK: 12 watios.
¿Y eso ilumina las luces de la casa?, ¿cuántas luces?
WK: Cuatro bombillas y dos radios.
CA: Wow.
WK: Sí.
Y entonces, (Aplausos) -- siguiente imagen --
¿y quiénes son ellos?
WK: Estos son mis paders, comprando una radio.
CA: Entonces qué les pareció -- que tú tuvieras 14, 15 años en ese momento --
entonces ¿qué les pareció esto? ¿se impresionaron?
WK: Sí.
CA: Entonces, cuál es tu -- ¿qué vas a hacer con esto?
WK: Um --
CA: qué es vas -- quiero decir -- ¿quieres construir otro?
WK: Sí, quiero construir otro --
para bombear agua e irrigar -- para irrigar cultivos
CA: Entonces éste ¿tendrá que ser más grande?
WK: Sí.
¿Cómo de grande?
WK: Creo que va a producir más de 20 watios.
CA: Entonces, ¿podrá proveer de irrigación a toda la comunidad?
WK: Si.
CA: Wow y ahora estás hablándo aquí en TED
para conseguir alguien que podría ayudar de alguna manera a --
¿a hacer realidad este sueño?
WK: Sí, si ellos me pueden ayudar -- con materiales, sí.
CA: Y si te proyectas con tu vida en el futuro,
tienes 19 años ahora, ¿tú te --
¿te ves siguiendo con este sueño, trabajando en energía?
WK: Sí. Todavía pienso en trabajar en energía.
CA: Bueno, William, es verdaderamente un honor tenerte en la conferencia TED.
Muchísimas gracias por venir.
WK: Gracias.
(Aplausos)